[Music]
[Applause]
he's a Frank Isola the Annette Studio
host and you can see him on uh Around
the Horn pardon the interruption also
Sirius XM NBA Radio Frank thanks for
joining us I'm going to make you the
commissioner
what do you want to do and what will you
do with the owner and Joker in that
little incident last night technical
foul on Matt ishpia for flopping who
looks like a young Tom Izzo I think he
could play Tom Izzo like a 35 year old
Tom Izzo if they ever have a movie about
Tom Izzo so he looks like his former
coach you know what I would not be
shocked if he if he gets suspended I
hope that he doesn't I think the fact
that jokish went to grab for the ball
first ishpia hold it away then it should
be a first touch yokich and jokic is a
big guy just kind of put his arms up
there was no swinging involved I hope
that's not the case it's interesting I
look you know I was watching last night
when Monty Williams came on after the
game I was wondering if Monty was going
to go down the Pat Riley Route or Phil
Jackson of course uh Monty's first NBA
coach was Pat Riley and said something
along the lines that we can't have this
in our sport we have to protect the fans
at all costs I understand Nicola jokic
is a great player but this is something
the league has to look into to Monty's
credit he just said I didn't I didn't
really see what happened
well I wonder if there's enough there
that the commissioner would suspend
Joker
um if this is regular season as opposed
to now would it be a different ruling
for for this and if it was a true fan
here because I think the Joker doesn't
know that that's the owner of the
Phoenix Suns
yeah a couple of things you know didn't
it was in Phoenix with the Clippers in
the first round
where Russell Westbrook kind of cuts
through they go cut through a shortcut
and there was a fan a knuckle had yelled
at Westbrook he confronted the fan you
know Kirsty threatening the guy he got
his he's got his kids his kid right
there there was no suspension there I
also wondered Dan the fact that it isn't
just a regular fan maybe in this case it
would help you catch out because why is
Matt ishpia taking the ball and you know
ripping it away from jokic to begin I
don't really think Matt ishby shouldn't
have done that I don't think it's a uh
crime against humanity that he did it to
me jokic is still mostly in the wrong
but I thought the tone of it last night
I guess they're going to interview jokic
about it I I ultimately think he'll be
available for game five let's hope
that's the case because you look at that
game last night those three guys Kevin
Durant Devin Booker and Nicole jokic I
mean they're just at a different level
offensively and how do you punish an
owner
well he he did replace a guy that they
essentially got rid of I mean I know he
stepped down on his own so I guess you
can I guess you can do it but that's
here's the thing Dan and you know this
and you've talked to him a million times
what if that were Mark Cuban
who in the jokic had pushed and now the
series is tied at 2-2 I would think now
Matt ishma may say something publicly
but I think he'd be well within his
right to tell to call up the league and
say hang on a second I paid what four
billion dollars for this team you're
gonna have a player treat me like that
he should not be available for game five
in this series so I'm sure there's a lot
of stuff going on behind the scenes
that's for sure see I hold the owner
more accountable than I do Joker
in terms of uh I thought that Matt
ishpia you know escalated this like you
know he held the ball he flopped he got
back up and then he leans into jokic
yeah I I think ultimately the league
will look at it that way and jokic I
thought his comments
um were pretty smart after the game I
think Michael Malone as well I thought
there was a chance that when the game
ended
I would now I understand jokic is upset
with the way that his team played down
the stretch that hey he had the big
turnover I was wondering if he was going
to make a b line for Matt ishpia and
just kind of shake his hand and I wonder
if that would have diffused it even more
well I but I again you want to see all
these guys out there and they did set a
bit of Oppression so uh Draymond Green
gets suspended for stomping on a sabonis
but in the release they mentioned they
factor in priors past transgressions
Nicola jokic yeah he had something with
markif Morris what was that last season
was two seasons ago when he you know
they got into it but nothing over the
top so I that will probably help jokic
as well
I'm watching the 76ers and the Celtics
and I'm not sure if either team is
really good I I think the Celtics can
play really good but then down the
stretch I'm just never quite sure uh
James Harden I'm never quite sure embiid
had a tentative 34 points if that's
possible uh but how do you how do you
kind of handicap that series between
those two I know it's strange and the
amazing thing too about Boston and I
think they have the most Talent top to
bottom out of any team I thought that
was the case entering the playoffs
certainly now as well now that
Milwaukee's gone
but you know Boston is seven and eight
in their last 15 home playoff games it's
a little hard to believe and they were
in a similar situation last year when
they went home for game five tied 2-2 in
the second round with Milwaukee ended up
losing game five but then they had the
great game six where Tatum went off then
they won game seven but I didn't
understand Boston yesterday so they're
up to Jalen Brown ends up doubling off
of hard today's NBA is now the MVP of
the league has got an angle with Jason
Tatum guarding him he kicks it out to
the three-point line Hardin is open
knocks down the shot all right so you
messed up defensively you're down one
why are they walking the ball up the
court yeah the idea now is to shoot with
what five or six seconds ago seven
seconds to go because if you miss and
you don't get the rebound now you can
foul you have two timeouts you can
extend the game I get it at the end of
regulation the game's tied and Marcus
Smart takes the last shot it's a wide
open shot no problem with that they
didn't they didn't even get a shot off
yeah in overtime and they're only down
one point with two timeouts it may made
no sense the way that they played that
but the odds to win the NBA title
according to DraftKings this morning
Celtics
Celtics are big favorites over the
Lakers
it it's amazing right really for the
first time and I understand the Knicks
are in a bad spot but I mean how often
can you really look at all eight teams
in the second round and if things were
to break right and for some of the teams
like the Knicks and the heat things
would really have to break right for
them to win it feels like you could make
a case for just about any team right now
winning at all and it's amazing with the
Lakers and give Darvin ham the head
coach a lot of credit Rob palink of the
moves that he'd made you know they were
a laughing stock at the start of the
season and now here they are on the
verge winning a home game of going up
3-1 in the series can you imagine if we
end up with Lakers Celtics yeah in the
NBA Finals but I still think the Celtics
are the best team I still think they'll
figure out a way to get this done and
you know what's interesting is when
teams play defense we we never talked
about Golden State's defense when they
were winning those championships they
played great defense they really did and
the Lakers played great defense
unbelievable defense and I give a lot of
credit to Darvin Hammond because guys
don't want to play defense you're almost
I have to encourage you to play defense
I never have to encourage anybody to
play offense but you know Vanderbilt
seems to set the tone and and so does
that head coach there can they continue
can they continue to win with defense
here in this I think they can if Anthony
Davis stays healthy and I don't
understand his scoring is always up and
down but if you have Anthony Davis
protecting the basket and then you have
a lot of inexperienced players but
LeBron James is like the middle
linebacker on the team he's standing
there telling everyone what to do at all
times so despite the fact that a lot of
guys aren't experiencing big games
having LeBron on the team is absolutely
huge but again I think a lot of it will
come down to how well Anthony Davis
continues to play what I also love about
the Lakers if you go back to that game
that they played in Boston remember when
LeBron did get fouled by Jason Tatum and
the referee didn't call it LeBron fell
to his knees and the big theme after the
game was oh we don't get any calls we
don't get any calls they led the league
in free throw shooting and even in that
game which was a blowout they took 20
more free throws you know than the
Golden State Warrior so they're really
good at drawing fouls getting to the
free throw line making shots they seem
to be in a pretty good position but
again the warriors were down 0-2 to
Sacramento they needed to go on the road
and win a game five and then they won in
game seven on the road so and I guess
it's 28 straight Series where they've
won at least one road playoff game
tonight should be the night Frank I solo
the net Studio host you can see him on
the round the horn pardon the
interruption also Sirius XM NBA Radio
LeBron talked about his son brawny going
to USC and that he really wants to play
at least one season with him uh so you
got this season then you'll have next
season and then
bronny I guess will come out into the
draft and then he and LeBron will how
does that work how do you think that
they sync this up that they play
together I mean we know that that's the
father's dream
and his goal is to play with his son in
the NBA but I don't know is that the
sun's goal right away just to leave
College after one year you know he's
going to school not many kids go to
school with I think it's a six million
dollar nil deal that he has in total
I don't know it's probably fun going to
USC is probably a great time to begin
with much less being a star athlete much
less being a guy that's getting six
million dollars a year so maybe Ronnie's
gonna like the college life maybe he
wants to stay two years in three years
which kind of pushes it down hey he
might not be making six million a year
as an NBA player he's certainly going to
be making it as a college player what if
he wants to stay he's not staying for
more than one year you never know no no
this is so important to his dad hang on
a second what if this year and this has
happened before he wouldn't be the first
highly touted high school player that
struggles a little bit his first year in
college I hope that's not the case but
now the competition is going to be a
little bit different he's going to be
playing in a really good conference I'm
sure you know because of his name
unfortunately for him he's probably
gonna have a Target on his back so but
it makes it easier than to sign with a
team that your dad's on because then he
won't get drafted a hundred percent not
but if you're a GM of a team in the
second round wouldn't you maybe want to
take it yes I would yeah
and he's not even the best player in his
recruiting class at USC but he has
gotten better which is what you know
anybody wants to see you know how much
growth their potential is there and it
seems like he made a big leap this past
year but I it seems like this is the
last thing that LeBron wants is yeah I'm
sure he'd take another title in the
process but he wants to be able to play
with his son absolutely and I thought it
was really sweet when LeBron did say you
know he kept saying that USC is getting
a really good kid and if you talk to a
lot of I've spoken to a lot of Scouts
that have been to his games and they
talk about Ronnie James being a really
good teammate how he's very unselfish I
mean LeBron is like that too very
unselfish teammates that that is good to
hear because when you're growing up I'm
sure for all these you know kids of uh
you know famous players it can't be easy
and it seemed like the kid has handled
everything really really well yeah he
has yeah and you're able to stay home
and go to school yeah
and he can so now he has the benefit of
his not only can his parents come to the
game he could still sit courtside at
Laker games that's a perfect perfect
scenario he's got it all I brought this
up last week you know because this isn't
really a rivalry between LeBron and and
uh staff or Golden State and the Lakers
I mean there's no real heated rivalry
there but this feels like it's a legacy
rivalry with LeBron and Steph of if one
gets another title so if Steph gets up
to five
does that change the conversation of his
place historically
um can he can he move past LeBron I I
don't I don't believe so I just think
it's an all-around player it's just a
little bit different and I also think
you know the fact that Kevin Durant went
there for a couple years it's funny they
were both born in Akron they were both
born in the same hospital so whoever
wins the most should really be
considered the real king of Akron
LeBron just can't take that title I I
think that they Aspire for a little bit
bigger kingdom here than than Akron you
know name the uh you know the Maternity
Ward after uh exactly there you go one
of the guys there all right great to
talk to you Frank thanks for joining us
as always buddy uh Frank Isola Nets
Studio host also uh Sirius XM NBA Radio
you can see him on around the horn and
pardon the interruption